Space anta dare to do mo Force Caster Lady
No,
that trash has increased a lot now When the trash hits a moving artificial satellite, it still affects our
gps,
financial transactions,
navigation, and various world life.  As the amount of trash
increases, it
can no longer be used in space, and it becomes full of trash and cannot be used at all. A new artificial satellite cannot be
launched, and people can go to
space.  Ah
seio sony Medium pacer Jenny's seb 0 out of 4 types
I chose the magnet because the
other person
really comes to those pants.
There are some
techniques with this, but if you do a little with the robot arm, the other party will easily go far
and fly away, so
you need very precise control with sanitary foam
[]  Music]
pou dou dou
Mickey Starch ben Justin Space Punch Habit Tinager
When I was in junior high school, I saw Independence Day and the
spacecraft in space had a very beautiful shape and I wanted to make it.
C  1 Chung and the story losangeles g
Name easing Brother who do Sports Program 4
ab Zu Kai Half The
impression of making a new thing as a Heisei engineer and working properly is
really big, and
it's fun to live behind that sign
.  Intififteen c joias scale of
this party surface Mission chain office space tv at Otsu Amister Chap
Space is a country-led day
Space development has been promoted so far?
I want you to enter. I
'm staying at a hotel in space, going to other stars to go sightseeing in space,
re beef patty asd counselor beep i started to
do space 4 minutes pawn  Sew  ok Paron Frosting
c certainly has some failures, but
just passing the failure
leads to success by collecting it and dic, so now the bar
is a little worried, but that's
all successful.  I think it's the way to the tribe, and it's a challenging thing. It
's exciting.
[Music]